one of the revelations we got here uh we
got a tweet here from Matt taibi an
internal email from November 5th 2022
the FBI's national election command post
which compiles and sends on complaints
sent the SF field office a long list of
accounts that may warrant additional
action and what what I find truly
shocking here is at RSB Network right
side broadcasting network this is the
FBI reaching out to Twitter saying
scan through a news organization's feed
to see if they broke the rules now I
understand that we're in a new era and
it's hard to separate an individual
account from like a news media account
but so long as these journalists want to
play the game I will come out and say it
right away the FBI
telling Twitter to take down an
individual wrong
the FBI telling Twitter to take down a
news organization now that's where it
gets real creepy they say
this is the email asacc Chan the
national election command post anycp is
requesting assistance from SF regarding
coordination with Twitter specifically
any CP has been made aware of tweets by
certain accounts that may warrant
additional action due to the accounts
being utilized to spread misinformation
about the upcoming election specifically
NS necp is requesting the following one
coordination between SF and Twitter
determine whether the accounts
identified Below have violated Twitter
terms of service and may be subject
any actions deemed appropriate by
Twitter
two the issuance of preservation letters
regarding this account identified below
in order to preserve subscriber
information and content information
pending the issuance of legal process
and three any location information
associated with the accounts that
Twitter will voluntarily provide to Aid
the FBI in assigning any follow-up
deemed necessary to the appropriate FBI
field office now there's a lot of names
in here you got Billy Baldwin of course
down at the bottom but RSB Network that
one uh that one stood out to me they're
directly the FBI was directly trying to
shut them down what do they do they live
stream Donald Trump's speeches for
instance things like that what date is
that I can't see
this is November 6 2022 right before
this midterm didn't Elon Musk already
buy the platform at this point
I think he I thought it was like end of
October yeah he did so Elon he was still
going through everything you know at
that point and there's uh some leftists
who are roasting him saying how many FBI
agents still work at Twitter and it's
kind of like you know that's not an own
right that he doesn't know that that the
FBI infiltrated this company the the
estimates uh that people are sharing
around and talking about is that there's
about 15 uh individuals connected
previously to intelligence agencies uh
to organizations like the CIA and FBI
that have been working at Twitter at the
time that uh Twitter was acquired by
Elon Musk so uh why does uh online
social media company need spies to work
for them I don't know but that's a
question that I think a lot of people
should be asking themselves since
um again 15 people from the intelligence
State going from working at the CIA to
Twitter why I see I would ask like
what's the reciprocity right like if
you're an intelligence agency and you're
going to let someone go right you're not
going to offer them a new contract they
have security clearance to go work for
Twitter like what is Twitter getting
from you I don't think this is a one-way
street it's not the FBI only getting
stuff from Twitter what protection does
the does Twitter get from all of the
agencies that it recruits from I mean I
I also I would love to know that as well
I also would just say I feel like
Twitter bred a culture that they
probably would have just welcomed it
without any any repayment right without
any reciprocity because whatever they
can do to get the narrative that they
want to get and you know they've got the
FBI giving them cover almost right
because they're like well the FBI is
telling us to do it so we got to do it
darn you know I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if they just did it just
because they're like oh gotta do it oh
will it will it influence elections ah
gosh darn it or or they had dirt on some
of the high-level Twitter employees like
yoel yeah they might have caught with
some precarious uh you know material
understand the computer and then the FBI
is like hey we got you on this uh you're
pretty much our female dog now we're
gonna do what we want with you
um so it's time to ban all the satire
people now family's a friendly way of
saying it yeah that's yeah a very
family-friendly show here very
professional uh here all the time
non-stop all right now to get not family
friendly Matt Tybee tweeted instead of
chasing Predators or terrorists the FBI
has agents lots of them analyzing and
mass flagging social media posts not as
part of any criminal investigation but
as a permanent and in itself
surveillance operation people should not
be okay with this yet for some reason
all of these woke journalists are really
really mad that Elon exposed this
they're doing things like mocking it as
nothing or just saying there's no news
here they're downplaying it to the best
of their abilities now that's strange
why why would anyone do that why would
so so-called you know Anarchist
socialist revolutionary types sorry
sorry look they do call themselves
anarchists though they're not they're
Communists they're commies why would
they
not what shouldn't they be excited the
FBI is being exposed for these illicit
undertakings
not when they've been working with them
and benefiting them for so so many years
now essentially putting their putting
their opponents in prison right right on
the surface level of course we could go
back to you know the Occupy Wall Street
days it was a totally different
political landscape that landscape has
changed and a lot of people are becoming
bigger and bigger statists depending on
the government depending on them to
carry out their own kind of will onto
others and uh it's sickening I I it's
it's it sucks when I don't care what
party does it but when you start to
imprison people for their political
beliefs when you start to impose your
personal beliefs onto others uh I
believe that is uh you know a recipe for
a disaster I don't think America's built
for this particular way and it's showing
us how biased everything is how unfair
everything is and how only it's going to
be more unfair from here and well I mean
what you're saying too is that these
people don't have true morals or
convictions that they live by they just
as Luke pointed out they just want to
impose their will on everyone else so
when it's convenient they'll love things
like freedom of speech and freedom of
the press and when Donald Trump threw
out one CNN journalist from the White
House Press briefing room but left
another CNN journalist from the White
House Press briefing room you know the
first amendment was under assault and
you know he was such a threat to
journalism now all of a sudden you're
seeing this and crickets because they
don't actually have those convictions
they have none they just pretend they do
when it suits them I think the only
thing they actually have is they're a
raucous mob and they just want to see
more mob violence there's no end goal I
I view it like a chaotic destructive
force is a fire it is destroying it is
spreading and we need to put that fire
up that's it because you look at a lot
of the positions they take they don't
make sense like according to the woke
left Luke is a person of color I'm not
kidding wait recognize yeah because
because Luke is Slavic he is not white
despite the fact he is a white blonde
hair blue-eyed man that's why my voice
is most important here but he's not the
right kind of blonde-haired blue-eyed
person right no you're are white despite
you know you guys having similar hair
and eyes but Blue's not yeah yeah I stay
in your place and that's and that's I've
always been fine with it it's okay it's
big
it's be quest for political dominance
they are using sophistry and any
ridiculous argument possible
that's it yeah I mean you can't you
can't make sense of the you know the the
illogical I mean they do it all the time
with all of the uh the drag queen stuff
that I'm exposing right they're like
well but yeah no it's we it's it's
family friendly there's they're just
dancing with the just the cleavage and
but then you know they talk about
Hooters and all these other things and
you're like wait it but can we all can
we just agree can we can we have a moral
can we have a value and can we agree
that if it's wrong it's wrong and then
let's just live by that no because no
one can't do anything to be gray area
because then you can they can move you
more and more away from what you believe
is wrong right if it's the great if it's
great it's negotiable uh I find myself
thinking when we read this tweet about
all the True Crime fans that are out
there right now who are big on like
researching old cases and stuff and it's
like if you ever get to a case where
there were the FBI were like we don't
have the resources we don't have the
time to help you like remember this is
what the FBI has been doing you know
like any time there's a crime where you
actually need the FBI's assistance and
resources and access to whatever
technology like they're busy on Twitter
you yeah but dude I mean Mean Tweets
that's true I forgot my feelings they
might hurt someone's feelings I was
talking about look the the kids they've
already been exploited someone's
feelings could be hurt and they could
stop those feelings from being hurt
there you go I was logic I was talking
to um Brian on the way here and we were
talking about uh you know I think Ted
Cruz was asked recently when all of this
I think it was after the FBI raided
Mar-A-Lago and Ted Cruz was asked about
it and he made the comment I think we
should defund the FBI
and they took it and they tried to act
as if he had said something so crazy
conspiratorial controversial they're
like Ted Cruz said we should defund the
FBI and I'm like yeah
and
I'm sorry is that explosive yes we
should I think it's funny that there was
a period 2020 they're like deep on the
police and the rights like now now come
on you're going a little far with it and
now the rights very much like well you
know I don't know about completely but
um there's certainly a lot of law
enforcement problems especially at the
federal level yeah now the conversation
but what I loved is that when the when
the Right started embracing abolishing
the ATF the IRS the DEA and the FBI and
the CIA the left started mocking them
I'm like whoa whoa guys guys if you want
those things too you've clapped for them
but a lot of these people on the left
don't actually want these things they
want it on the federal level they don't
want you to have a state police force
but they do want you to have Central
authoritarian control well they're
they're it's it's the Democratic it's
the Multicultural democracy versus the
constitutional republic the
Constitutional republicanists or
constitutional republicanism wants there
to be decentralized to a certain degree
with you know various jurisdictions and
the left is the multiculture
Multicultural democracy that wants no no
jurisdictions but the federal government
top down tells you what to do the Mob
Rules there's also a lot of
conservatives calling for that too A lot
of them who wear CIA pins a lot of them
who call for more Federal governments
and more Federal interventions and more
Foreign Wars so there's also a neocon
aspect to this that I think does get
addressed that has been kind of
unfolding within this kind of right-wing
party which is uh very interesting to
see because it's kind of
counterintuitive to itself when you see
that do you see do you find that it's
mostly like older establishment type
people who have been in politics for a
very long time well like Sean Hannity I
think Sean Hannity is a perfect example
of the Old Guard who wants government
loves government loves the intelligence
agencies loves back the blue and the
police uh and is it isn't open to
criticism of his own party of their
failures so I think those individuals
are very different than individuals like
Tucker Carlson who are able to criticize
individuals like Donald Trump who are
able to question the Deep State what
Tucker Carlson said last night about the
CIA and the JFK files was extremely
eye-opening and very brave of him to do
that so I think when we have individuals
like that there's a big difference
within this kind of right-wing party
that I think is not uh coalesced
together thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time